rating is approaching 2700
but okay just have to focus on the
moves so we have a main line
[Music]
tonov it's been a while since I've
looked at these
[Music]
lines
what to do what to
do
I'm out of specific
prep I have the bishop
Hair King is UN
castled and G6 might be
coming as
95 like F4 Knight
G4 uh feels like I just have to react to
What White's
doing
so I have three Pawn Islands but no
isolated
pawns Bishop F6 Rook C8 I mean there's
definitely ideas
[Music]
here be this first
delaying Rook C8 because the Rook might
be useful on a or
B8 have to watch out for this x-ray
vision now it's no longer an
issue so B3
B3
A3 but A3
E5 my opponent's pausing because they
see okay E5 now E4 is a target it's hard
to remove the queen here there's no good
move to attack the queen for
white the thing is even if I win this
Pawn like White's King is going to be
safe for a long time
time like maybe someday I sack on
A3 one think I'm just realizing if the
Knight moves here or here I take and win
the
Knight basically winning a
piece it's still
tricky okay hitting the
pawn and I'm up a piece but white has a
center probably safer King
to
Castle I like my knight
here H6 maybe H6 maybe I
take might be
threatening doesn't quite
work Queen A6
[Music]
um
got to watch my
time the queen might slide all the way
over Rook wants to
participate
Bishop C2 is actually an interesting
Square for the
bishop would allow
E6 but okay E6 Knight
D6
idea Rook
C2 oh my knight oh
no someone call ambulance St my
Bishop ah someone call ambulance a my
queen oh no
someone call an
ambulance but not for
me
oh such a funny
line I saw this line I couldn't resist
going for
it I think three ambulances are coming
now all for this
king that's a cool meting idea to sack
the Knight that the bishop and then the
queen okay that was a fun start it was a
scary
position very fitting for
Halloween yeah the triple ambulance
Gambit
uh explain all caps yeah so the reason
for sacking the Knight or the reason for
Knight D6 I want to improve the Knight
but I also wanted to get my queen here
and after takes takes it's actually very
hard to
stop the threat of mates like I'm
threatening Maiden two with Queen DS
A3 and I assume black I
mean materials equal but I think black
should be winning
here let's
see White's best move Queen takes
C2 was Knight D6 the best
move it's one of the playable
moves okay